what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg and John here today
to watch the final episode of secret
Invasion today and before you guys ask
where koi is we have no idea where he's
at based off of knowing koi he is more
than likely asleep right now and
traditional koi fashion he is not
fulfilling his contractual obligation
and is missing the final episode of the
Disney plus Marvel series that's just
the way it's tradition koi operates just
like at our Comic-Con panel he was
nowhere to be seen for the first half of
that entire time he got there eventually
so who knows maybe he'll show up for the
last five minutes we'll actually Miss
Marvel you missed the final episode
and then he was here for it so I'm the
only reliable one around here yes truly
guys I did want to say a thank you to
everyone who did attend our Comic-Con
panel uh it's some of the compliments
that we got even from the tech team
there uh where they came out to us while
the other battle was going on it was it
was so unbelievably kind what everyone
was saying to us and it was such a blast
with that in mind too you guys might
have seen I was drinking G fuel when I
was there and there's a reason why G
fuel is arguably the best brand that
real rejects has ever partnered with
yeah guys there's a special code in the
description box to get yourself uh
discount on select tubs there I think
every single flavor we've ever had has
been delicious and I I rely on them they
got me through Comic-Con they get me
through most days of the week I
certainly mean that so thank you to G
fuel for sponsoring this video and I
shout you guys out even when you're not
sponsored for a reason because I I
really do love them it's a great way to
support the channels making yourself
some g-fuel with that in mind leave a
like on this video also be sure to check
us out on patreon as well where you'll
catch the full interaction watch along
for this thank you to all who have
joined us let's get to it
all right let's do this let's do this 20
minute episode of finale where nothing
will be rushed
purple squirrel Blood on the wall
koi is it the first time you call this
number in years
I have dialed this number a million
times
no you'll be coming
oh all right I'll uh I'll let you go now
oh you don't have to if you don't want
to darling go to her
take care of yourself
Priscilla will return
I'll get the romance I keep begging for
oh yeah
not bad actually a cool shot yeah it's a
really cool shot
they couldn't tell that from the
distance
damn Fury how'd you set that up how
long was that car going for
our Republic
orchestrated by the skrulls and the
Russians who are giving them safe haven
discussions negative I suggest you move
on to doing what it is you were summoned
here to do present the president of the
United States with his options to Russia
you know Roadie you've had a lot more
propaganda in your language lately
the rhetoric is really through the roof
what are we looking at here Colonel
Rhodes I love that Dermot Moroni showed
up to have like five lines in this whole
show yeah now sir if I may I've taken
the Liberty to prepare a rough copy of
your remarks to the nation carpet bomb
they need your leadership they need to
understand who's responsible for this
and it's the Russians 100 it's the
Russians it's the Russians Russians
Russians Russians
it's always the Russians and a little
bit of the Scrolls
I think this is Gaia I think this is
Gaia yeah it's Gotta Be Gaia
foreign
radiation poisoning
God guy is really in character
this episode's bringing back a little
more of that cinematography I was
admiring in the beginning star strong
and strong baby you have to get him out
of there Fury's headed straight for you
smart he wants Ritz and stop before the
bomb it's launched move the president
now
oh maybe she's Gaia they're all Gaia
foreign
[Laughter]
locked away
looks like it's just you and me fury
I need a lozenge no more protection for
you
how about a drink instead I'll do the
trick yeah
I put a lot of sugar in it for you
it was Ant-Man using my skin like a
costume a costume Fury do not recognize
this skin this face
this was the first human I killed an
Abercrombie model I killed him because
you told me to
oh wow ah it just doesn't stop
everything's your fault I killed him and
I killed so many more and everyone I
killed took a little piece out of my
heart blames him for everything I'm
supposed to be like Talos and put my
trust in you you pimped us Fury oh and
when you were done with us you threw us
away so
first I'm gonna kill you no no he's in
the Marvels
impossible so I am absolutely clear
about this Fury you look at me look at
me look at me and the massacres and the
wildfires and the imminent removal of
humans from their habitat that is all
you
that is some good acting they were
condemned to Die the day I realized you
weren't a man of your word
it's okay for squirrels to go to therapy
[Music]
betterscrolls.com you're right I I
failed you
I failed you I'm sorry I knew the only
way for me to keep my end of the bargain
was to build your home here
why didn't you do it oh it's easier to
save the lives of a billion people weird
audio than it is to change their hearts
and Minds sure the last thing I felt
before I flake dog flaked off
relief sure relief that I didn't have to
fight anymore that I finally had a way
out
I believe you actually said
we're spam doctrinated
I should have taught you
never
who's doing this killing I've decided
give you what you want
Carol Danvers DNA no way whoa take your
powers go to some other planet wipe out
some of the species I don't give a damn
really
call off the strike and save your people
oh
I think the radiation's in your brains
mate
what's the ultimate plan here Fury
coughing is an act
you have a war machine suit and you're
protecting the president who was just
attacked
by what you telling people are Russian
and scroll forces
put it in the crisper
whoa damn like everyone's name is here
Rockstar's gonna have a great time yeah
it's the entire End Game Cast no
checking behind the doors you really are
a scroll I don't know what it is you
think you're doing just Jules back into
the hallway go on
has she been doing all this herself
that's how it appears right now because
I mean she's like invisible yeah maybe
she got powers we don't know about
Fury is going to get power yeah what are
you doing
makes you buffer goodness
it does look like abomination
yeah what is happening
what powers did you get
Hulk Hulk Fury
do that AI music
oh there you go it was a Gaia
H well done girl
oh Nick Fury really was going yeah sure
put that together right when we realized
you killed my mother
my father prepare to die I have the
magnet
ah Drax arm yeah
I think he did sprout an Abomination
arms
[Music]
oh my goodness phasing guy ghost
is a court group
wow this Atari
pretty much Atari Frost giant maybe I
better get Frost Giant
grow
dozens of world officials
along with Colonel Rose they're positive
the president isn't a scroll
happen anymore
oh this is like more secret Invasion
because
a lot of powers are adapting yeah and
they're doing them like quadrants of the
body just stay the course
right and all our enemies will be gone
yeah
yeah get got it it's a great argument
there roadie
Zion
[Music]
power battle
sleep
did he have a Thanos arm
purple arm
this is pretty cool I'm all of a sudden
excited for your ass I hope she doesn't
die now
[Music]
yes
just like them that's a good thing yeah
damn oh my God
and just like that he's dead yep
so long compelling villain did really
make much of a moment out of that but
okay so who's that
yo whoa
right the forehead
oh it's fine Jesus somebody give me the
phone
that
there's parts of that fight that I
thought were really cool it is also what
the She-Hulk finale was making fun it is
I wonder if he'll regenerate or
something does the maybe flip that on
its ear a little bit
real man
just the actor himself I'm an agent what
you've been held hostage
for a long time for how long exactly I
totally forgot about oh yeah they might
be down there yeah all right the
terrorists responsible
shape-shifting alien-born species known
as skrulls but they're not all bad
presenting to Congress for immediate
emergency authorization a bill that
designates all off-world born species
enemy combatants oh boy and we will kill
every last one of you that is not what
Nicholas Fury was hoping for he is
return to form without making a moment
out of it he just walked into frame yep
he's back cued the music
the trailer had more of a moment
don't worry he's still got like five
minutes left gee they can still put
punctuation on this walking through I
know who I am when you're not here
is when you come back
that I start to wonder did you fall in
love with me
yes or the face that puts you at ease
The Fetish is what he filmed
love you Priscilla I love your ass
you can find a way to forgive me
you know where to find me
I'm sorry is that the direction of that
series is done so flat so weird
we meet at last
oh complimentary colors opposition
you'll need resources to fight this war
that Ritson has launched on your people
and I can give them to you the British
versus Americans well let's be sure not
to repeat the mistakes of Talos and fury
and leave love and friendship out of
this
I will use you and you will use me
together we'll make this planet safe for
both our people 50 Shades of Gaia yeah
dude Gaia and Sonia will return what the
hell is all this
this is how enemy got so good
what are they gonna do
you took a bad situation and made it
worse oh no one-term president stuff
that's real Harrison Ford is replaced it
up now oh my God damn
oh geez did not say that
wow now you got dumbass Vigilantes
killing innocent humans too oh this is
Bleak when it hasn't killed himself
oh boy
oh we needed more of her she's awesome
if you truly care about the Scrolls
get them off my planet
your planet
[Music]
how long do you think we're gonna forget
about this scroll plot points
[Laughter]
hold a minute
hard to just hold this thing still
she gonna go with him yes do it go to
him
whoa this is so like E.T close encounter
right
romantic Encounters of the Third Kind
Priscilla Vara
now that humans know we're among them
I'd like to use my birth name
good news from saber Cree said they
opened peace talks with the scrolls are
they setting up Marvels
which friend reached out to you Chris
said they're open to peace talks what do
Scrolls call good luck
bad luck stop it it's a good thing I
don't know man my hell yeah with this
you know this peace Summit
crease Summit I'm no good with people
you are you've got your own way oh cool
I'm sick of it I guess the scroll thing
is going to actually factor into the
marbles could do please
come with me
Come With Me Now
I'll help you get started huh but then
I've got to get back
oh my work is here darling he arrived
alone and now he's leaving with someone
yeah full character Arc
um I just wanted to tell you that
that I love you
as I am
ah only
two
which is best character this year
100.
yeah they want honor
look how far we've come
oh it's like cover art I like it I like
the way this looks
actual romantic moment
hell out of here
here they go
there they go oh what a great last shot
to become one
show's over and I guess agent Maria Hill
just is dead that was the first episode
that said it didn't have her as a guest
star
Moment of Truth
moment okay drumroll koi was asleep you
got something back what'd he say
damn it man you missed so much could
have pointed out the one or two power
sets that we did not properly call well
I'm sure screen Crush heavy spoilers and
you rock stars are gonna have fun
breaking down and deciphering every
single power that we saw in that fight
scene uh I don't that's that's not what
we do what we're gonna do is give our uh
analysis A Commentary of course a review
of the episode and factoring our
experience of the entire season as a
whole as well that's what we want to do
today and
I'll let John go first since John tends
to be the nicer one always out of
everyone who ever comes on this channel
that's right kind Johnny uh you know
this was a a decent finale in my eyes
there were certainly this exemplifies a
lot of the things that the show has been
up until now there are a lot of really
nice scenes I think this is one of the
better ish overall episodes but you know
the season as a whole has had this
quality of like yeah certain parts are
really cooking certain things are very
intriguing certain ins uh certain
relationships are easy to really latch
on to and then other things feel a bit
perfunctory and feel a bit kind of
rushed and you know sort of by the
numbers or or at least like they could
have used an extra ounce of inspiration
or oomph or something and no well I know
I'm saying I'm I'm the hot takes today
all right I'm saying what no one's uh uh
brave enough to say there are Wars there
are worse finales of this on the Disney
Plus show oh certainly more
disappointing ones I would say yeah and
there are probably more inconsistent
shows than this one like ultimately I
liked no this was on a steady
deconsistent it's on a steady decline
naturally God it was on a gradual slope
down to being fine yeah yeah yeah
Blended on a fine note yeah and it's
like I don't want the the response to
this to teach the wrong message because
I really like what this was going for
and by extension I think the easiest
Marvel series up until this point to
compare this to would be Falcon in the
Winter Soldier and that was another show
where I was like I really like what you
guys are going for and obviously that
was hampered by other circumstances but
you know both of them are shows where
you're like ah you you got close to
something really interesting and cool
but you kind of you know settled for
like yeah you know a surface level
depiction of this kind of yeah conflict
and again I don't want to keep harping
this point but in a post and or world
you just know that it's possible to
reach those Heights of like oh all the
cool sci-fi that we want out of
this franchise plus real world
ruminations and you know gray areas of
socio-political economic Espionage and
things like that
um I like this as a as a wrap up to
especially I mean Nick Fury and
Priscilla is like the best part of the
show named zafara Vara sorry I didn't
mean to get a dead name and um but yeah
like that's easily the heart and soul of
the show I liked some of the wrap-ups in
terms of you know finally getting to see
some of those Powers come to the screen
but for every piece of Praise I have to
lump on this as there's also a gripe or
a complaint or a knit to pick you don't
have to John you could be the guy who
likes everything okay I love this you
guys best finale best show most
consistent content out of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe quote me on that uh
yeah I mean it was really obvious that
it was going to be Gaia there uh did it
make sense to me that Nick Fury would
show up for the fight
I'm really conflicted about a lot of
that uh like the fight in and of itself
and the one I have a dichotomy about it
and the great words oh duplicitous I do
because there's so many things I liked
about it and then there's so many things
contextually that I'm like but wait a
minute then that's where I'm really
coming from here like I really thought
gravic's speech the entire time he was
lamenting his Sorrows his pains upon
Nicholas Fury and all the blame for his
actions are just being projected onto
him the entire time and it was it was a
really impactful moment and the first
like 10 minutes or so of this episode I
I did think they were okay they're going
back a little bit more to what I was
really loving about this show uh within
the first two let me get to the first
three episodes like the things that I
still loved about the first three
episodes
and and then of course the speech and
Nick Fury is giving back
but the fact that it's Gaius the one
who's saying it I'm wondering what my
takeaway is is that supposed to be Nick
Fury's Arc
or is that Gaia coming to an
understanding finally you know of this
is what uh that her dad like why her dad
believes so much in Nick and now she
sees the perspective and now she's on
that side is she did she have this
conversation with Nick Fury and now
she's like my last time before I flaked
away I'm like was this a thing you
discussed with Nick yeah between the
last episode of this one Nick was like
here's everything you gotta say because
she's not like cerebrally hooked up to
him and you know the way how these other
scrolls are
so to me I'm like who's our does this
belong to right now is this a Gaia Arc
is this a Nick Arc is this anyone's Ark
and that's why I I feel conflicted about
that moment because
it was really apparent that it was going
to be Gaia and then the plan in and of
itself I thought was a little ridiculous
like that could have gone so awry that
could have gone I I don't think that was
thought out at all of what she did I'm
gonna give him this
and we're gonna battle it out you can't
count so much on him being okay with
Nick being in the accelerator machine
the reactor whatever it is as well and
it's like he could have easily been like
no
beyond that it counts on the fact that
she would like they don't know what
powers they're gonna get yeah and that's
and while I think there's something so
cool contextually about everything
everyone having this amalgamation of a
billion different Power sets that are
all coming through and it's cool to see
on screen and for someone who read the
secret Invasion comic book I'm like all
right now we're doing a little bit of
secret Invasion stuff like we've had the
whole paranoia thing down of who's a
scroll and now we're doing the element
of watching a a uh a scroll adapt Powers
now they're just combining it all in
like two characters right and you know
visually it it wasn't bad to me you know
I I think it's Marvel especially uh it's
an easy thing to knock at when it comes
to their visuals and I'm like come on
we've we've seen worse oh sure we've
seen worse and all things considered I'm
like this is pretty cool like there's
something pretty cool about it
but like I said the the idea behind the
plan is a little too far-fetched to me
and it seemed like an excuse to go down
that Disney plus throughout that that
that
She-Hulk directly makes fun of for what
the shows do yeah to get to the point
with big VFX fight scene thing
especially with two characters who have
all these personal charge Stakes pointed
at each other to just culminate in yeah
like a smash them up battle and then
graphic just gets murked on the spot no
you know unceremonious death I mean like
you get the speech but that's pre-fight
you need a moment after the fight to
send them off at least his death was so
on what was so lackluster uh the way
that went down just an easy beam to the
chest you know like I thought it was
such a weak death scene especially for
such a great like a really well written
and well-performed villain yeah I
thought I was really I I did not I I did
not like that and what I don't like in
in situations like this especially is
them learning Powers is them going
I'm looking at it all right I got it I
just can just imagine what to do yeah
and and I I I generally don't like that
at all like no there should be some
figuring out of what what to do you both
even Captain America when he's first
running in that movie he's like well I'm
running yeah
yeah like and they're each being
overwhelmed with an influx of like every
conceivable power from everybody who
showed up in the end game battle pretty
much so yeah I mean the fact that
they're immediately jumping to like I
got four quadrants in my body all
different powers and I'm wielding them
dual and it's no problems whatsoever I
think it's really cool I thought there
was like cool parts to it overall the
Gaia character
um I think Emilia Clarke she really I
think she showed up I think Amelia
Clarke uh really did her her best I
don't feel like the show ultimately gave
her much to do in the end uh I I think
that her character was underserved it's
Amelia Clarke who I do think is a really
great actress and I I wish that they
gave her more substance or something
more to chew on versus what we
ultimately got here giving her moments
to Nick Fury yeah
and giving it I don't know that give her
stoicness you know and it's an
interesting thing to leave off on her
with with her and Olivia Coleman and
like them teaming up and I'm just gonna
have this like the the most ultimate
super scroll the only truly I mean she
seems like one of the most powerful
beings in the whole MCU
beat like everyone yeah Captain Marvel
Powers Thanos powers and she's
overpowered power uh Frost giant Frost
Beast Frost giant like frost Giants and
Thanos and and you've got everyone and
everyone characters who haven't even
been named in the universe yet massively
overpowered yeah massively overpowered
yeah from like the good uh from the hero
and villain sides alike yeah it's it's
it's a little ridiculous and you thought
people were like Captain Marvel over
powerful guy you know like that is so
that's so crazy you can see what what
she can do
um cool to behold the image the imagery
was very cool like again that was the
most excited like I think her best
character scene was in an episode or two
ago with Vara when they are bonding
that's like easily the most Vivid Gaia
character moment but in this episode I
mean you know I I did like that they
even though the Nick Fury thing is kind
of confusing like her getting to at
least talk about the release of death I
thought was kind of like a moment where
they sort of overlap and you're like
okay I can see where you two have sort
of a similar experience here but perhaps
but yeah
um written I think that so much of the
interesting nuanced commentary where I
was crediting this show so much for not
being a black and white conversation
suddenly everything devolves into a
black and white conversation and it just
becomes a dick yeah it was written
especially I'm like yes I think like
is that the likely response if we're
going off a real world situations of
course uh if we're if we're thinking
topical of course yeah absolutely I do
think it the way the show handles this
like slingshot effect though especially
when Nick Fury was the one who saved his
life
and Olivia Coleman does it's both Olivia
Coleman and Nick Fury there I'm like
what was the conversation there because
clearly they must have had a
conversation with the president that did
not communicate to him of like actually
it's a little there's some bad ones and
there's some good ones just look how
there's some good humans and some bad
humans you know well and Talos you know
Taylor saved his life saved his life and
it seemed like something that Nick would
go out of his way to communicate the
fact that they don't even have this
conversation pop up in the show is
really upsetting to me yeah uh when I'm
like that was the whole freaking point
of Taylor saving him that was the entire
Point yeah so it was death goes unjust
in that moment
um so that's annoying to me there's a
lot of problems I got with this film I'm
not gonna lie I got a lot of issues yeah
and funny enough for for I feel like
we've all been sitting here on a lot of
these lately going man I wish they would
like kill off some characters or make
some steaks and I feel like this series
killed off a few characters and yet I
feel like in some ways those characters
were less you know killed for a great
impact or some kind of massive change
and more sort of slighted because like
yeah if this is the last we're going to
see of Talos or Maria Hill yeah like I
don't think It ultimately served the
entirety or or some big purpose to do
that especially if we're not going to
come back around and go hey this guy
sacrificed himself for you let's get
some kind of Memorial now this whole
fight is done for Talos or something
because it's a character I feel like
people like and have been endeared to
and it's one of The Shining parts coming
out of Captain Marvel through this yeah
and I mean even Maria Hill like I you
know I always got excited to see her she
gets a prominent presence in the first
episode and then once we move past that
it's just kind of done well then they
had her funeral and he said he talks
with her mom and you think there's going
to be some type of top of episode two
yeah you think it's going to be some
personal uh Conquest that Nick Fury is
setting out on it does not go that
yeah that's where it ends off on so okay
I I I get the set up it's like it seemed
like they were just in a hurry to get to
the plot set up for where this girl's
going next that segues into Marvels
where obviously the cree are going to be
in Marvels and maybe they will actually
address the whole scroll thing which is
a big deal first Korean squirrels to
possibly
get the hell along you know that's a big
deal
um uh and and I I hope the movie does it
I I hope the movie shows that uh or
unless like we solved it off screen yeah
I don't know what they're gonna do
but cool fine
um I I guess I'm excited for that uh but
yeah I mean I liked uh Nick Fury and
vara's final moments here there are
things that there's whole this whole
thing with I
I can't believe in the trailer they had
the whole thing with the reveal of Nick
Fury will eventually come back to being
you know him yeah and then here just
like walks in the house yeah like don't
make a moment out of it yeah and I can
it's itching for that so much I'm like
you could have it just treat it like
it's nothing yeah well yeah and it's
torn between I think it's torn between
being those two different kinds of shows
the version where it's like badass
comeback finally I've returned to my
full form versus going like understated
and more intimate with it and I feel
like here it postures the intimacy and
mostly leads with that leg hey kind of
energy and then in moments like that
we'll like randomly go flat and I like I
can't tell if stuff was retooled or if
there were just certain things that you
know they were more enthusiastic about
than others when it came to like really
bringing these moments to life on set
like it is like an odd show because it
doesn't feel as like Jagged and
inconsistent as some shows do but it
will travel from feeling quite inspired
and quite Punchy to feeling like again
perfunctory a little bit or sort of a
workman-like I mean I I like the uh the
darkness of the final moments where
you're seeing Humanity
you start going crazy and just like
taking things into their own hands yeah
because it's all like national
television and um it feels real it's
just like it's just so kind of harsh and
Stark and just like oh wow like those
people just got mowed down yeah yeah no
it's a TV studio at the same time I do
think that the movie is paid the show's
pacing uh
undercuts the moment so much it just
felt like it had to move so fast that it
couldn't really sink its teeth it tried
to do you have two really long First
episodes like what what mandate was
ordered yeah who decides these things
and why are all the show like why why is
there a consistent issue with the
lengths of these shows well it jarringly
became shorter yeah it jarringly became
like kicked into like a higher gear it
went from like almost an hour long for
the first two which I really liked both
and and I know there are people like I
saw people in the comments in the last
episode going this is probably my
favorite episode uh and I'm I'm that's
again that's good for you guys if it if
it is your favorite episode uh
uh I I cannot say that anything has
reached the heights of the first two
following this I I think this is better
than
episode four and five I I like this more
than episode four then I think I do I
don't know I really don't I don't even
give a honestly uh I I don't know
I'm sorry I I doubt it one two six three
four five one two and we're great and
three was the second one below them and
then after that it's a mixed bag to me
uh for four five and six uh so yeah this
this was
um overall the finale of of it all that
I thought was very much I still thought
it was a mess and as while there were
some exciting moments to be had I still
thought it was very messy
I didn't dislike it to the point of
do you see the thing is like when I
think about Moon night and I think about
Hawkeye
uh I remembered the penultimates really
liking yes you know yeah being like whoa
this could make maybe maybe like nail
yeah and then the finales I was like oh
wrap this all up yeah yeah we're here I
was like
well the show's been going downhill for
me so yeah I'm not exactly disappointed
us with like 50 minutes I'm like I had
fun
I'm not going to think about it ever
again probably to me this is like the
most consistent of the inconsistent
shows because the ways in which it is
inconsistent are quite consistent across
the show itself like I I like the tone
in the atmosphere and and most
everything I think that gets so lost
though over time like the same work
remains but yeah all that stuff gets
lost no yeah I'm not gonna pretend like
this is a show that is marked to me by
the the potential it's like there are
moments when it's hitting the potential
there are a lot of moments when it's not
I like the general veneer of what the
show is and I hope that they don't
decide not to pursue this flavor in the
future because it does feel a bit
different and it does feel in that more
again Espionage not to everyone always
pulls Winter Soldier and this doesn't
feel exactly like that but this feels
yeah like oh the kind of government
conspiracy side of all this superhero
and uh you know infused World
um and I like that they spend the time
and energy to do that I just yeah I I
wish they could iron out the consistency
Factor because this is yeah it's like
when it's flat it's not terrible and
it's not like completely out of line
with what's come before it's just yeah
it's just doesn't have the room to
breathe well guys uh
that those are my thoughts
um I
if you don't really want to watch the
show I think you just think out of all
the shows this is the one you could just
read what happens in it sure if you
really don't care to watch out of all of
them you can just like look up what
happens in it if you want
um so yeah uh what did you think about
it though what are your thoughts we're
here to just share ours uh that's our
review so leave your thoughts down below
um
hopefully Marvels is good and hopefully
so and we'll see how how much they
factor in humanity worried about Scrolls
moving forward or unless it's just
another plot line that I just introduced
and we ultimately don't really think
about it in the end
um
all right we'll talk with you all soon
thank you to G fuel I gotta edit